[Musik]
[Applaus]
einen wunderschönen guten abend sehr
verehrte damen und herren im namen des
österreichischen bundesheers heiße ich
sie herzlich willkommen zum
militärmusikfestival 2018 hier in der
salzburgarena im wunderschönen salzburg
mein name ist sabine petzl und es ist
mir eine wirklich große freude sie durch
diesen ganz besonderen aufregenden abend
begleiten zu dürfen
herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
dankeschön mit dem einmarsch der
militärmusik salzburg unter der leitung
von militär kapellmeister oberst
professor ernst herzog durften wir mit
dem jaguar marsch dieses musikfest
eröffnen und hier kommen auch schon
unsere gäste aus den bundesländern
begrüßte sie mit einem wirklich
herzlichen willkommen es applaus die
militärmusik tirol mit herrn militär
kapellmeister oberst professor johannes
ab folterer und dem marsch des
österreichisch ungarischen soldaten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die militärmusik vorarlberg kommt mit
dem marsch unter der montfort banner zu
uns in die arena
angeführt wird sie von militär
kapellmeister major wolfram eller ein
willkommens applaus danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das herzlich willkommen an die
militärmusik kärnten mit militär
kapellmeister oberstleutnant diesmal
brannte sich brief für uns den kärntner
lieder marsch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und mit dem diesmal kommt die
militärmusik niederösterreich zu uns
herein voran marschiert militär
kapellmeister oberstleutnant minister
adolphs obendrauf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
richtig mitklatschen ist sehr willkommen
jederzeit erlaubt die gardemusik aus
wien fürs militär kapellmeister
oberstleutnant johann kaust zu uns unter
den klängen des marsches ehre und
pflicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein herzliches willkommen auch der
militärmusik aus dem burgenland unter
der leitung von oberst hans merkel mit
dem 76er regimentsmarsch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
klar ob not least mit dem einmarsch der
militärmusik oberösterreich unter den
klängen des hessen mars unter der
leitung von vize leuten und josef
strasser sind wir dann erst einmal
vollzählig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
diese sicht ein wunderschöner anblick
meine damen und herren was sagen sie
vor allem die damen
ja die spannung steigt sie sind alle
schon sicher sehr gierig die
darbietungen zu sehen und zu hören es
gibt auch gleich los ich möchte ich nur
vorab bei ihnen für ihre freiwillige
spenden bedanken zugunsten von licht ins
dunkel
die für einen guten zweck zusammen
kommen also sie können auch weiterhin im
laufe des abends noch spenden vielen
vielen dank
wir freuen uns wirklich sehr dass sie so
zahlreich gekommen sind und wie immer am
beginn einer solchen besonderen
veranstaltung müssen wir natürlich
ehrengäste begrüßen
sehr geehrter herr bundesminister für
landesverteidigung herr mario kunasek
weiß ich nicht mal wo er sitzt da oben
er gibt uns die ehre heute abend
herzlich willkommen
dankeschön für die vertreter der
gesetzgebenden körperschaften begrüßen
wir herrn nationalrat ökonomierat franz
essl
guten abend
die frau bundesrätin doktor andrea eder
pitztaler in vertretung des herrn
landeshauptmanns von salzburg herzlich
willkommen sowie die frau klubobfrau die
landtagsabgeordnete marlenes watzek und
mit ihr auch alle weiteren abgeordneten
herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
weiter für die anwesenden hohen
vertreter des bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung und der operativen
kommandanten begrüßen wir den chef des
stabes der landes streite
landstreitkräfte verzeihung herrn
generalmajor heinrich winkelmeier und
mit ihm alle anwesenden kommandanten
soldaten und mitarbeiter herzlich
willkommen
[Applaus]
für die exekutive und die
einsatzorganisationen begrüßen wir herrn
oberstleutnant karl heinz wochermayr aus
salzburg sowie herrn
landesrettungskommandant georg hat soll
aus kärnten und mit ihnen natürlich alle
weiteren vertreter der
einsatzorganisationen einen schönen
abend innen
[Applaus]
für die traditionsverbände und wer
politischen vereine begrüßen wir den
präsidenten des österreichischen
kameradschaftsbundes bundesrat und
bürgermeister außer dienst herrn ludwig
bieringer herzlich willkommen
sie haben einen tollen platz da oben
für die österreichische blasmusik darf
ich sehr herzlich den präsidenten des
österreichischen blasmusikverbandes
herrn erich riegler und mit ihm alle
anwesenden musiker sehr herzlich
begrüßen
stellvertretend für die anwesenden
vertreter des zentralausschusses der
fachausschüsse und der
personalvertretung begrüßen wir den
vorsitzenden des zentralausschusses
herrn oberst peter schott visa herzlich
willkommen
[Applaus]
für unsere partner aus dem bereich
wirtschaft begrüßen wir den
vorstandsdirektor der wüstenrot
versicherungs ag herrn magister gerald
hasler guten abend
so wie wir unseren partner aus dem
bereich der deutschen bundeswehr den
kommandeur der gebirgsjägerbrigade 23
herren oberst stephan leonhard aus bad
reichenhall sowie unsere gäste der
militärmusik aus dem sultanat oman
mit der durchführung dieses militärmusik
festivals ist das militärkommando
salzburg beauftragt und für alle
mitarbeiter die die organisation der
veranstaltung geplant haben begrüßen wir
den amtsführenden militärkommandanten
von salzburg herrn oberst franz fritz
und militärpfarrer dich hat weidinger
schönen guten abend und vielen dank fürs
organisieren
[Applaus]
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
dieses militärmusikfestival ist jedes
jahr eines der höhepunkte des
ausbildungsjahres des österreichischen
minister mit der österreichischen
militärmusik und sie kommen aus allen
bundesländern zusammen sie zeigen ihr
können und musizieren gemeinsam unter
der gesamtleitung des militärmusik chefs
des bundesheers herrn oberst magister
bernhard her
[Applaus]
herr oberst her wird nun das kommando
über die angetretenen militärmusik
übernehmen und nach einer feierlichen
eröffnungsfeier von josef messner dem
herrn bundesminister die acht
militärmusik zur durchführung des
militär musikfestivals melden
ich wünsche ihnen jetzt vorerst viel
vergnügen genießen sie es
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
dankeschön sehr geehrter herr
bundesminister ich darf sie jetzt um ein
paar grußworte bitte danke sind wir
haben eine sehr geehrten damen und
herren sehr geehrter herr
militärkommandant geschätzte generalität
ehrengäste aber heute ganz besonders
geschätzte militärmusiker es ist mir
eine sehr sehr große freude heute in
salzburg zu sein und ich glaube eine
stadt wie salzburg eine stadt der kultur
der musik hat er sich mehr als nur
verdient dieses tolle festival heute
hier auch genießen zu dürfen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren die acht
militärmusik die heute hier ihre
leistungen auch zum besten geben sie
unterhalten dürfen sind ganz besondere
repräsentanten und groß botschafter des
österreichischen bundesheeres und als
verteidigungsminister bin ich sehr sehr
stolz darauf dass sie nicht nur diese
leistungen erbringen sondern auch in
voller stärke wieder für uns spielen
dürfen und ich darf an einen ganz ganz
großen applaus noch einmal für unsere
museen bieten
[Applaus]
im applaus nach zu folgender ist es ein
klarer auftrag an mich wie vor der
stärker zu halten und so wird auch so
sein wenn es sehr geehrten damen und
herren
aber meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren wir heute hier in diese
wunderbare halle gekommen sind diese
musikalische grußbotschaft wie wir heute
hier von salzburg aus senden möchte ich
auch in das zeichen jener soldaten
stellen die heute nicht hier sein können
die jetzt im moment dienst am vaterland
der verrichten in den kasernen an der
österreichischen grenze oder auch weitab
fern von der heimat nämlich im
auslandseinsatz und möchte diese
veranstaltung auch in das zeichen dieser
soldaten setzen und auch für diese einen
applaus bitte wir wünschen können
er wird jetzt ist somit weg mit einer
grußbotschaft am endlich darf war immer
meine sehr geehrten damen und sie haben
heute eine wunderbare eine wunderbare
veranstaltung wünschen
genießen sie die militärmusik aus acht
bundesländern
ich komme öfter in den genuss und weist
der verbrauch welche großartige
leistungen die musiker und musikerinnen
es sind ja auch 33 mit dabei heute hier
auch verbringen und leisten können
herzlichen dankeschön eine art danke ich
darf das mit ganz kurzen loswerden auch
sie dürfen jetzt diesen weiteren abend
genießen wie wir alle hier so zahlreich
erschienenen gäste an all jene die
dieses spektakel vielleicht noch nie
gesehen haben ist irgendjemand es noch
nicht gesehen hat jetzt zum ersten mal
hier bei militärmusikfestival ja doch
einige ihnen kann ich versprechen sie
werden so gepackt sie werden so
gefesselt sie werden so mitgerissen
werden heute abend von dieser kraft von
diesen jungen damen und herren von
dieser musik und sie werden es spüren
musik ist und bleibt eine verbindende
eine kraft spendende und überströmen der
macht sage ich immer der man sich
einfach nicht entziehen kann
der marsch den sie jetzt gleich hören
stammt von franz lehar dessen 70
todestag sich heuer jährt und zu diesen
klängen werden nun alle militär musiken
aus marschieren und draußen aufstellung
nehmen für den ersten teil den showteil
dieses militärmusikfestival 2018 und der
titel dieses marsches passen da geht es
nicht ist jetzt geht's los mein herr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein applaus für alle unsere helferlein
heute abend
[Applaus]
diesen tagen hier beschäftigt sind alles
für sie aufzubauen
genau das war mal ganz wichtig nun
beginnt also wie gesagt der showteil und
die gastgeber also dass gastgeber
bundesland die militärmusik von salzburg
darf beginnen mit dem arnheimer es folgt
dann meine heimat mein salzburg das ist
ein trompetensolo und natürlich welcher
maßstab in salzburg niemals fehlen wenn
wir eine große veranstaltung haben der
der einmarsch richtig und dann folgt ein
schlagzeug solo des schlagzeugers orbis
der militärmusik salzburg und ich glaube
die herren sind bereit so aus ich mache
mich jetzt aus einem stab damit ich
nicht im weg bin
genießen sie die militärmusik salzburg
herr kapellmeister bitteschön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich stelle mich jetzt schon mal da ist
nämlich so eine schöne lücke unglaublich
ich möchte nicht unerwähnt lassen die
namen der jungen herren her vom
schlagzeug aussage der militärmusik
salzburg das ist der korporal corny zur
julian wer ist das aufzeigen der freitag
eigener gabriel gefreite eiserner peter
gefreiter gold martin warum gefreiter
keil alexander und die gefreite
rohrmoser theresia
[Applaus]
das nächste jahr das nächste mal
burschen möchte ich aber auch dass die
dame und daher mit dem becken eine led
led effekt hat geld die sind so arm ohne
lichter aber ist er sich großartig ich
frage mich flickte auch mal was daneben
beim proben dürft ihr reden mit mir auch
jetzt schon das heißt ja nicht so eine
andere welt leute oder genial also du
darfst mit mir sprechen ja geht er auch
beim proben manchmal was dann eben beim
proben schon beim auftritt und
hoffentlich nimmer
das nenne ich professionell also es ist
wirklich großartig dass da wirklich
immer jeder zwei stx hat immer zum
rechten augenblick eine große applaus
noch mal für die militärmusik in salz
vor herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
so jetzt mache ich platz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir kommen nun zur nächsten show
darbietungen und zwar kommt die aus
vorarlberg die militärmusik vorarlberg
feiert heuer ihr 60 jähriges jubiläum
und daher sehen sie meine herrschaften
heute eine wirklich brandneue ein
brandneues showprogramm der landes
stabführer des vorarlberger
blasmusikverbandes eric bürger hat ihn
gestaltet und er besteht zunächst aus
einem kleinen traditionellen teil da
hören sie bekannte melodien wie den
deutschmeister regimentsmarsch den
kaiserjäger marsch mitsingen jederzeit
erlaubt geld und dann ein moderner teil
in memoriam udo jürgens mit 66 jahren
weiters in memory um falco amadeus
spätestens da haben sie gänsehaut das
sage ich ihnen und joe zawinul mercy
mercy mercy und abgerundet wird das
ganze vom radetzky marsch
ich wünsche ganz ganz viel vergnügen mit
der militärmusik aus vorarlberg herr
kapellmeister bitte wo sind sie denn
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das war unsere gastorchester auf dem
schönen vorarlberg sie haben uns das
warten auf das neujahrskonzert auf
wunderschöne art und weise verkürzt mit
dem radetzky macht es immer wieder
mitreißend oder ja was ich nicht frage
ist ich meine musik studieren ich weiß
ein bisschen wie das funktioniert mit
den blasinstrumenten und so und diese
blechbläser wenn man weiß wie der ansatz
von seiner tuba oder einem tenorhorn
oder einem horn funktioniert dann frage
ich mich wie das machen dass sie dabei
auch noch marschieren und sich drehen
und eigentlich tanzen also allergrößten
respekt vor dem was er damals
[Applaus]
bevor wir alle in eine 30 minütige pause
gehen möchte sie noch darauf aufmerksam
machen dass sie in dieser pause draußen
im rundgang die informationsstände der
verschiedenen militärmusik besuchen
können es gibt cds zu erwerben und alle
möglichen anderen kleinigkeiten und
andenken davor aber gibt es jetzt noch
im showteil eine darbietung von der
gardemusik wien mit dem schock in der
garde und zwar unter der leitung von
oberstleutnant hans chaos und der musik
meist der vizeleutnant gerald springer
die gardemusik wien nimmt sie mit auf
eine musikalische reise
zunächst beginnt diese reise in new york
mit dem wunderschönen titel ich war noch
niemals in new york geht es weiter nach
portland von joe zawinul und wird dann
diese reise kurz unterbrochen von einem
schlagzeugsolo mit dem titel wien bleibt
wien geht es weiter und dem
deutschmeister regimentsmarsch es folgt
dann noch oh du mein österreich nicht
vergessen mitzusingen und zu den klängen
von the view zeigt das shooting der
garde akrobatische einlagen beim
exerzieren mit dem gewehr und auch dann
gibt es noch einmal den radetzky-marsch
zuhören können wir nicht oft genug hören
meine damen und herren die gardemusik
aus wien mit dem showteam der garde
herr kapellmeister bitte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
euro
[Musik]
[Applaus]